latest developments on coronavirus now
and Italy has just announced it will
close all of its schools and university
remember Italy the highest number of
factions in Europe and has been
scrambling to bring the spread under
control Jonah hull in an hour European
news center in London with more on this
one Jonah yes you said Italy currently
dealing with the most severe outbreak in
Europe over 2,500 cases 79 deaths
remember just 13 days ago they had only
three cases so a very rapid spread
happening in Italy confined mainly to
hotspots in the north of the country but
spreading elsewhere as well and Italy
really stepping up its efforts now to
deal with this outbreak drafting in
health officials to the worst affected
areas calling on the EU to allow it to
breach its budget deficit and spend as
much money as possible on this thing
there are talk there's talk of a new red
zone or red zones of quarantine in the
worst affected parts of the country so
we may yet see things like city wide or
town wide lockdowns on the same sort of
basis as we saw in China the most recent
line in the last hour is that Italy is
closing all of its schools and all of
its universities until mid-march so a
pretty strident effort there to halt the
spread of viruses in though of the virus
in those institutions that along with
news that sporting fixtures were there
for some days now they've been calling
off or postponing big sporting fixtures
or Coppa Italia match between Napoli and
Inter Milan is the last the latest to be
called of it was scheduled to happen on
Thursday the 12th match at the top
flight of the game to be called off
there's warnings coming out from the
president of Italy's higher health
Institute this will strike a particular
cultural nerve in that country asking
people no longer to kiss each other on
the cheek in greeting now or to hug each
other in greeting and it is thought
perhaps colloquially that that is a
widespread cause of the spread of this
disease in Italy but Italy clearly
struggling to cope struck
to contain this virus but doing all it
can okay Jonah hell thank you for all
those updates on the situation